c'est très simple à chaque fois la
personne va prendre un ingrédient haut
et va le mettre dans ce mixeur et
ensuite à dire à chercher une carotte
ici celui qui aura la plus petite
carotte de voix brard tout le mix and
ben oui mais non on sait qu'il va se
faire
vous jouez avec nous bien entendu
attention c'est parti on va démarrer
avec julien mazy julien tu penses que tu
veux comme ingrédient est une mais dans
déjà parce que je pense que tu prennes
français très bon voila voila pour le
coup c'est là que mon cv je suis pas du
tout content mais très très bien qu anne
frèches effet et julien tu vas prendre
une carotte
je prends une carte vous attire ouais
bien sûr que tient la carotte
[Applaudissements]
apparemment tu fais bien attention
bernard montiel alors l'ingrédient je
vais prendre je suppose que c'est du
tarama oui bah c'est marqué dessus bah
oui merde c'est pas mal bu un peu manqué
au niveau de la lecture
et voilà il a versé du travail est
content bah oui c'est réglé et tu vas
aller me chercher une carotte
alors je prends avanies
[Applaudissements]
alors gardez vos carottes bien en vue à
la marsa belmont ibos ça fait longtemps
qu'on ne l'avait pas vu alors il fallait
pas dire planète et on va dire voilà a
pas obligé de céder sa fille on est
obligé de citer d'autres crème
chocolatée mont blanc et autres merci
ses dégoûts allez c'est parti
ben aziza tu prends tout de suite d'un
point qu'a carottes mais aussi c'est
toujours nous épaulent waziers nouvelle
carotte mais voilà le tableau des
maisons souvenir attention gilbert bête
en poisson qu'elle attend d'avoir la
gueule quoi ça peut être moi et toi
ça doit le sont gardez vos carottes pour
la scor laisser les façons on le sait +1
pour l'instant que pour l'instant la
plus petite carotte c'est entre vous
deux tak tak chez vous la plus petite
carotte donc vous êtes tranquille ouais
voilà vous pouvez barrer vous par la
cgil l'amérique la hauteur c'est un
petit peu de fromage basque termine une
carotte qui le vignoble
choisissez bien
mais du temps je veux dire ces carottes
comme dans la vie merci c'est bon c'est
bien sûr c'est qu'annie pour l'instant
c'est toujours avant jc web choisir
l'accès de l'avocat tout à tout est
parti ces offres à boire l'ensemble du
mixeur vas-y c'est maxime gagné tu te
mets là on l'attend tu te mets là vous
réveiller à 12h 46m à côté du mix est là
et tu mets ta carottes bien dans vue ont
montré que la plus petite carotte
on me dit qu'il peut y avoir plus petits
bah ouais ça vous relater ce vendredi
benjamin castaldi
on me dit qu'il peut y avoir plus petit
bazar on achète d'avoir posez vous les
bonnes questions questions
calmez-vous baby est ce que c'est ça la
soupe de poissons soupes aux légumes
allaient bon voila merci sur faussement
celui qui va boire ça jusqu au lac
albert
[Musique]
il a pris 2,42 ou jouissent et de la
mort dans ces canaris dans la même
petite nahla il rejoue les restaurateurs
vous vous retournez vous allez rejouer
ah oui bravo ah oui ça c'est intelligent
et la stèle du sua de bolt disqualifié
je regarde totoro pas la démo m'a dit
vas-y vas-y nadine bouchra klaoua c'est
bon c'est bon
karaté vaisseau aller s'il vous plaît
géraldine maillet moi je vais des
carottes à vaalimaa fais toi plaisir
elle a passé les cas c'est bon géraldine
magna ou sony c'est une carotte
je rappelle qu'on joue à qui va se faire
40 et qui aura la plus petite carotte
quand vous avez mis tout à l'heure là on
a tous regardé où elle et elle l'a vu la
première audience au port 12 je vous
l'avais pris matière à toi vraiment des
douleurs c'est pas moi si ça doit trois
à six mois d'intervalle et gaffeur et de
moutarde
allez chercher votre 40 points sedan
c'est maxime guennic à la plus petite
carotte
vous vous en doutiez chez vous allez lui
paraissait bon allez jean michel six
mois et c'est dingue à plein de sa c'est
tout le monde se met la bouche à l'arrêt
tout surtout joué en rester là matthieu
delormeau voilà parce que je n'ai pas pu
aller bien non
c'est pas possible je savais qu'on
allait faire sa saison deux chefs 2 mais
ne s'était pas mettre les jaunes c'est
graal mots là bas avec nous on y va
prenez une carotte la fidh et la [ __ ]
emparé prix de carottes et dont la
petite donc vous retrouver vous vous
retournez artois il ya des sauterelles
je vais pas remettre ces carottes toute
la journée
alors vous regardez pas une fois tu vois
le la et je fais des piteux regarde la
syrie va aller maîtrise il est de
traiter les plus riches pour mettais
trop de temps à l'éviter allez allez bon
travail allez oui ait choisi ma carte
pendant que la foule attendait mais moi
fondamental et toi et les vélos de façon
bon maxime elodie fontan qui est avec
nous la pauvre elle était venue ouest on
a mis un peu de sucre et le gars qui va
voir ça ou la fille c'est impossible
attention attention elodie choisissez il
reste quatre joueurs
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je n'ai pas d'avis tri c'est l'avis des
[ __ ] d'hérault non non non nous
accusent en revanche pas nous les filles
n'ont pas si matthieu delormeau d'abord
on termine en partie avec beaucoup plus
d'elodie ça me fait beaucoup de peine
c'est un méga m'apprendre cultes y ait
trop de couleurs pourtant à coeur mon
coeur et de disney coeur alors voilà
privé tessin et humain alors eh oh ça va
pas bien
attention je vous rappellerai sait plus
comment grâce à deux tirs alliés de tir
williams a également noyé
attention à ce que vous allez avoir une
petite carotte qu'elodie directeur
attention il ya match et enfin je vais
mettre un petit peu de vinaigre fois de
ma vie je suis plus petits qui doit
atteindre l orgasme
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît on
triche pas attention ne triche pas on
mesurera les carottes attention année
cyril reste mon coeur souvent les gens
qui sort vraiment réussi récompense
quelque chose
amélie tu as besoin quelques des petites
carottes mais la famille les dynamiques
pas faire une chanson pas vous voulez
tirer
quand vous voulez mais tant les séries
tout de suite la carotte de fifi ici
sentiment c'est la première fois qu'on
rigole comme ça quand tu sors ta carte
avec son genou avec 100 mais sans témoin
par la carotte d'elodie 3 aulas à y
aller à votre avis qu'est la petite
énigme à des parties fines avec ses
dérives dans cette histoire c'est que je
sais d'avancé que c'est moi qui vais
perdre parce que même si c'est elle je
pars à l'essai alors c'est à dire alors
pouces il s'écoute par jour la maison il
n'ya pas d'amitié
non mais je te le dis c'est chacun pour
soi ou sur bien garé fille je vais
mesurer mais elle a été raccourcie la
mienne ça soit réparé dire la plus
petite
c'est la plus fine oui elodie là désolé
de te le dire mais tu as la plus petite
carotte alors à temps vers un dernier
truc lui faire un dernier truc qui fit
je vais mixer
et après je vous dirai d'abord vous
allez devoir boire un verre elodie un
cette mixture en revanche je vais
laisser une dernière chance
en valais on va là d'un défi comme
j'étais finaliste et que c'est ton ami
si tu décides de prendre le gage tu
crois cra la carotte si tu poses la
carotte
cela voudra dire tu ne l'aidera jamais
au grand jamais leur voyage j'ai passé
des mois non plus tu crois que là car tu
crois que la carotte tu auras 5 secondes
si tu crois que la carotte tu dis je
prends le truc pour elodie si tu ne
crois tu pas la carotte tu laisseras
elodie voir la mixture il faut je crois
que la carotte et qu'en plus j'ai alors
attendu à 5 secondes non mais
franchement
julien tu penses qu'ils devraient dénis
l'estaca ratifie tu est extrêmement
court oui je tiens à dire que bien
actuellement kelly est la personne que
j'étais test le plus sur terre oui ce
serait un ami un bloc de roquefort comme
ça je détresse leur mort et moi j'ai une
berne et d'un couteau en tout cas est
battu ce sera la seule personne qui la
détestent le plus qu'agathe
[Rires]
c'est une scène maintenant les deux là
ça va comme tous les papas c'est
terrible l'émission a commencé là
malheureusement sardines d'annette en
ressort c'est bien comme fifi tu te
rajoute un peu doux à à ckoi change tout
la petite fille tu sais que tu es un ami
depuis des années je le croyais bien
fait dit tu as bien fait deux trois
petites filles mettre face à ses
responsabilités
soit tu dis oui je vais boire seul air
étudie ce ver l'écuyer par amitié pour
toi c'est vrai tu aimerais ça paraît
c'étaient les kroumirs tu dresses
apparemment si tu fais ça je dois me
demander beaucoup après ces beaux tutoie
de l'argent
[Rires]
les ardennes il pourrait le boire par
amitié oui moi je trouve ça très beau et
je trouve ça te flatte tu peux tu peux
décider de diamant je vais te laisser
trois secondes ok je vais faire une tête
de suspecte par une tête de con
également une tête de con las cabezas
pas au fait
merde ça ne marche plus apparemment on
peut pas voir le mixeur sinon on fait
sauter je connais moi
écoute irait que j'ai beaucoup appliqué
j'ai fait appel à un ami qui est mon
estomac
il m'a dit voilà faisait je faisais
syrie
[Applaudissements]
ces courageuses vous êtes un ami vous et
pour paris fait le malin mais plus tu as
l'air et la promo la razzia minarets
pour une fois que ça tombe sur la gueule
rien n'ira pas non
[Applaudissements]